what's your favorite Scar and what's
your favorite stripe favorite scar
probably this one right here Robbie
Lawler he threw an uppercut he's a
southpaw my head was on the center as I
was doing a double leg Against the Cage
we drilled in training my head position
probably a hundred times and uh in the
fight I thought I was faster I thought I
was better and he blasted me with this
uppercut just like we knew he would in
the exact same way that we had game
planned him to do it I trained correctly
I had all the knowledge and resources to
be able to not have this scar but then I
went on to brutalize him for 15 minutes
and ultimately win a pretty big big
fight over you know UFC welterweight
champion so I wear this chunky scar on
my nose with with pride in Special
Operations where like when you go
through that book when we went through
the legal review most of the names in
this book are dead now most of my
friends the stripes of me still just
being here I'm proud of those because
like the song rooster you can't kill me
yet